to avoid looking suspicious i tried to
interact with my mom
as little as possible thankfully it's
rude to speak with your mouth full
you look tired baby sleep okay uh-huh
so how big a tax refund you think we're
gonna get
[Music]
morning morning i slept in the nude last
night
fell every little breeze thank you for
sharing that
you're welcome
[Music]
there was only so much food i could eat
so
i started avoiding my mother whenever
possible
what are you doing in there keeping your
secret
you gotta pull it together this is me
pulling it together
yep got him thanks you're very welcome
hey have you noticed anything off with
sheldon um
no no no can't say that i have why he's
been
awful quiet and at the risk of being in
delicate
he's gone several days without a bowel
movement
how do you know that well i was worried
about him so i took a look in his potty
journal
still keeping that thing huh oh yeah
that's why he wanted the polaroid camera
i'm sure he's gonna be fine but i'll
keep an eye on him
thank you you got it
[Music]
thank you batteries are in this drawer
avoiding my mother in our own house was
proving to be difficult
so it was time to get creative hello i'd
like to book a room in your hotel
i'd be arriving tonight no it's just me
oh a queen bed that sounds fancy and how
much would this room cost
wow is that per month
per day by any chance do you have a
children's rate
we've been friends for a while now
haven't we
i suppose so given that how would you
feel about a sleepover
sure your mom lets you watch tv shaking
the fat man is on tonight
i meant we could sleep at your house but
you'll miss jake and the fat man
even better so what do you say
i'll have to ask my mom well be sure to
tell her i'm clean i'm well behaved and
if you don't have a lot of room i can
fit in really tight spaces
so your first sleepover pretty exciting
huh
no it's not exciting it's constipating
and i'm only doing it to avoid mom
stills for sleepovers
okay i know you're having a tough time
with this but
you're doing great spend some time with
tam's house
clear your head and come back home
refresh and then i can tell mom
oh no you can never tell mom wouldn't it
be easier to just be honest
usually it would be but sometimes the
truth can hurt me
we wouldn't want to hurt mom right of
course not
a boy
[Music]
you